[Music]
hello and welcome to safety ridge on
sunday after yesterday's very moving
funeral for the duke of edinburgh
politics
is slowly coming back into focus a
lobbying scandal that began with
questions about texts from david cameron
to rishi sunak has since spread across
westminster
it's raised issues about access
conflicts of interest and whether the
current rules are tough enough
and all of this comes as voters across
the uk prepare to head to the polls in
less than three weeks
well on today's show we'll be talking
about those elections the lobbying
scandal and
much more as well the snp leader nicola
sturgeon will be joining us as she
campaigns to win another term as
scotland's first minister
i've spoken to the united states climate
envoy john kerry ahead of a major summit
next week the environment secretary
george eustis will be here in just a
moment we'll be asking
him about lobbying and we'll also be
discussing that with steve reed labour's
shadow community secretary plus
i've investigated one of the tightest
election races
happening in england right now one that
matters an awful lot for both boris
johnson
and kierstama
but first david cameron once said that
lobbying would be britain's
next big scandal it seems that that is
one prediction that he got absolutely
right
but the concerns about the former prime
minister's own lobbying are just the tip
of the iceberg and the questions that it
sparked
go beyond him and throw into doubt
whether the whole system
that governs relationships between
ministers and those in power
is fit for purpose well to discuss this
we're joined now by the government's
environment secretary george
eustis thank you very much for being on
the program this morning mr eustace
um talk about david cameron in the
moment but just to talk about someone
who is still
very much a member of the government
first uh matt hancock
so he owns 15 of the shares in a firm
called topwood now that's a company
where his sister is a director it's also
approved as a supplier for the nhs
is that really acceptable well of course
the reason we know about this is that
matt hancock did exactly what
all ministers would do in this case
which is to declare that interest
and so he did the right thing he's
declared that he's had no role
whatsoever
in any procurement around this business
so yes there's nothing wrong
uh with ministers having financial
interests
provided they declare them in the
appropriate way
as long as you declare it you can do
whatever you want no
as long as you declare it and then have
no role obviously in any procurement
decisions around that company
that's the important thing here um you
know the important thing is is much more
how do ministers act and conduct
themselves in these situations if there
is a potential conflict
well the the thing they should do is
make sure they remove all of that
conflict by ensuring they have no role
whatsoever
in decisions surrounding such companies
but secondly declare it so there can be
no
perception that they might and so he's
done what you'd expect someone to do in
that case
you say there's no perception of a
conflict of interest because he's
declared it
you know i'm not suggesting that matt
hancock's broken the rules here
as you say he's followed the rules but
some people looking at this might think
that if a health secretary can
own a sideable chunk of shares in a
company run by his sister
that is then a supplier for the
department which he is the head of
then it's the rules themselves that are
broken
well i i'm not sure actually that i
would agree with that obviously look
ministers can move around a lot um
famously we tend not to spend
um uh you know too long in one
particular role uh
sometimes a minister will be given a
position and may have a long-standing
financial interest that they therefore
need to declare i don't think that was
the case in in this one but that is
often
the case and so they declare it in the
usual way and then remove themselves
from any
decisions that uh that might affect
their own you know financial interest
and as far as
that's exactly what matt hancock did i
mean the reason we know about this the
reason it's being talked about
is because he declared it and he did the
right thing yeah he did declare it i'm
not saying that's not the
you know what he did but at the same
time you know could you not understand
why some people looking at this might be
thinking
this looks pretty off shouldn't there be
more distance in place shouldn't there
be more rules in place
to try and make sure that these
conflicts of interest don't happen
whether or not they're declared
well look there's a lot of different
government uh what government inquiries
so the prime minister set up
uh nigel baldwin to look at the green
hill case in particular there's then
that's not looking at the matt hancock
case so no it won't but there's also
uh simon greensells looking at the issue
of civil servants potentially having
second jobs to make sure that there's no
conflicts there and of course then
there are several parliamentary
committees looking at this i think the
right thing to do is
for these uh reviews to go through their
process to conclude
uh to work out exactly what deal and did
not happen and then yes of course there
may come a time
uh after that when it's right to
consider tweaks to policy but
fundamentally
i think that the systems we have in
place with ministers declaring interest
with the ministerial code and the focus
on that and how
ministers conduct themselves uh in
office is actually a pretty good one but
that's not to say that you couldn't make
tweaks or changes
and also there'll be a time and a place
for that after these reviews have
concluded
let's talk about the boardman review uh
shall we because i understand that it is
quite helpful for when you know
ministers like yourself do these rounds
that you can point towards the fact that
you know the baldwin review has been set
up
at the same time though it's got no
power to sanction no statute or legal
force
and it's strictly limited to looking at
the greenself affair
i mean it sounds a bit toothless doesn't
it well no i
i think it's actually the right thing to
do because the you know the worst thing
uh for ministers is to to say that they
think everything's okay and then
suddenly it turns out that there are
other details that emerge and so the
prime minister
i think quite rightly has said let's get
to the bottom of this
uh let's have uh a legal professional
who's a non-executive director at the
cabinet office
to really look at this don't they need
more powers this is the point i'm
getting at doesn't this review
need more powers if it's going to be
taken seriously well i don't think it
needs
powers i think what it needs to do is to
get to the bottom of what happened
and then as i said if following that if
there's a a general view
in parliament that the rules around
declaration of ministers interests could
be
changed slightly or if there's a view
that
rules around what ministers can do when
they leave office should be changed
slightly well then that's a policy
decision
and that's something that can be taken
to the point but it doesn't this review
doesn't need
enforcement powers as such it just needs
to get to the bottom of what's happened
so will you
implement what the review recommends
then well the review is going to
establish
what happened uh in this particular case
i know what the review is going to do
but
will you commit to implementing what the
review well
i don't think the review is going to
make policy recommendations but of
course there are there are other
uh reviews going on in the park what's
the point of it
genuinely if there's no powers it's not
going to make policy recommendations
what's the point well because people are
raising questions uh about what happened
in this particular instance around
greensville both because there was a
yeah we know the questions well there
was a civil servant uh bill cruthers who
at one point was working for the civil
service and had a role
in greensville so that is something
that's being looked at
and obviously there's been a lot of
questions raised about david cameron's
contacts with ministers
so the purpose of the review is to
answer the questions
that people are asking um but it's not
really there to
prescribe policy so there are other
parliamentary committees
that are looking at this issue in the
round and i'm sure many of them will
make recommendations on policy and of
course government will always
look very carefully at what parliament
recommends in this space let's talk
about david cameron
are you comfortable with the way the
former prime minister has acted
well look he himself has said that with
hindsight probably would have been
better
if rather than texting ministers if he
had instead
written letters to set out his uh
his views uh more formally but i think
the the real
point is has he done anything wrong well
on the face of it uh no
but you know there's a review that's
going on we mustn't uh uh prejudge it
you don't think he's doing the thing
well look there are rules that say the
limit what a former minister or former
prime minister can do for a period of
two years
he meticulously observed those yes he
then took roles uh after that
did he exploit the rules this is the
thing it's like do you think that he
took advantage of rules that many think
were just two lacks
well i don't think he took advantage of
any rules now he meticulously observed
the rules there that he himself actually
put in place after uh some concerns
around lobbying a decade ago
he put in place these restrictions on
what ministers can do for a period of uh
two years but look he himself has
conceded that with hindsight if he had
his time again
he wouldn't have texted rishi sunak and
wouldn't have texted others
he would instead have written through
formal channels but the big question is
what did then
rishi sunak do having been approached
the answer is
you know he asked the question asked
people to look at this issue
the answer came back there was nothing
that could be done for this company
the company was told we're not going to
do anything at all to help you and the
company went bust so
at the end of the day um did people give
any special favors to
david cameron or indeed to greensboro he
answered that's no
you worked quite closely with david
cameron when you press secretary for him
when he was leader of the opposition
given what you know about david cameron
do you think that he's acted in a sort
of calculated way here
or do you think frankly he's just been a
bit of an idiot
well i wouldn't ascribe to either of
those definitions i i think look he
he uh abided by the rules that he
himself put in place and so
didn't take any uh roles for the period
of two years after leaving office
he's been out of office five years now
um and he left office when he was still
quite young
and that's caught from the case now with
prime ministers and you can't begrudge
people
a chance to do a different career and
something different after they've
left that top job i think everybody
would accept that
but look in terms of did he do anything
wrong well like he himself conceded that
the manner in which he approached rishi
sunak on this particular issue
uh on behalf of a company that he was
working for by text probably was
ill-advised and probably he should have
done it through a more formal route with
a letter
through his private office david cameron
himself conceded that and that he would
do things differently
uh if he had his time again okay um keen
to move on now to
uh covet um nhs providers warning this
morning that it could take
five years to clear the backlog caused
by the pandemic
how concerned are you well this is uh
obviously an important issue it's been a
huge
endeavor that the nhs have been through
to try to deal with
covid we've tried apart from those peak
periods
uh the government has really tried to
encourage people
with other routine operations to to keep
coming in when they're
able to when uh when the nhs hasn't been
at those peak periods
obviously people have been anxious at
times and obviously at times when the
nhs has been particularly stressed
they've had it they found it less easy
to take forward those other
those other operations but i know that
this will be very high
on matt hancock's agenda as we emerge
from the
pandemic making sure that we can get on
top of those
routine operations that are obviously so
important and that have
um life you know life consequences
themselves
um another issue that many people are
worried about at the minute is the
emergence of these new variants we know
about this
variant first discovered in india lots
of work being done to try and like track
exactly how much of a foothold it has in
the uk
and have you got the most up-to-date
figures on how many cases there are
the last i think i saw there were around
70 cases uh but i think
i've seen lots of different numbers on
different variants you'll appreciate
there's quite a few
so it's a it's a fairly small uh number
uh
at the moment but it is something that
we are watching
then i'm told that there's no evidence
at the moment that this
particular variant is able to
get around the vaccine for instance or
indeed that it's
necessarily more contagious than the
others but
we are looking at it it will be studied
we've got some of the best
genomic studies available in this
country we're very good at
genome sequencing four different
variants and that work is uh
is ongoing and obviously there's a wider
concern here the biggest threat to
everything that we're doing at the
moment
is that at some point there will be a
variant that manages to evade the
vaccine or
largely evade it so it is high on our
concerns which is why
well the the vaccine rollout has been
incredibly successful with over 60
percent of the adult population now
vaccinated
we continue to to proceed with some
caution as we come out of lockdown
um i'm interested to know why india
isn't currently on the uk's red list
this is the list of companies where
you're either banned from coming into
the country or you have to quarantine
for 10 days in a hotel
so at the minute in india there are over
10 000 covered cases per million people
if you compare that to 3 000 in pakistan
just over 4 4000 in bangladesh
pakistan and bangladesh are on the red
list
but india isn't can you reassure me that
this is science not politics at play
here given the prime minister's planning
a trip to india
look yes so the we have uh
an expert committee that uh that looks
at this and then
makes recommendations uh to the
transport secretary and matt hancock and
the
uh the group that make up the the covid
cabinet subcommittee
they look very closely at it and it's
then discussed
more widely it is reviewed periodically
so
you know roughly every every 10 days or
so they they look at this if if there's
a need to do something urgently they can
do that
but they do periodically review variants
that are in other countries and the
approach that we should take
we should bear in mind that everybody
coming here needs to get a pre-departure
test and also test after arrival
so that's an approach that we take that
we take now but for those redless
countries obviously
quarantines also required and i know
they're looking at reviewing this to
have a sort of
green amber and red approach to to
triage things more because
international traffic is going to become
a more important focal point as we come
out of lockdown
is it really a good idea for the prime
minister to be going to india
later this month when we know that
covered cases there
are surging i know there's a brexit
trade deal potentially riding on this
trip but surely public health has got to
come first
well public health does come first but
that doesn't mean that there should be
no visits at all for business purposes
and so
yes it's already the case people can't
go on holiday they can't travel at all
on holiday but for something like this i
think yes it is appropriate but look
absolutely
measures will be taken to ensure that
the visit is covered secure
that any uh staff and the entourage
attending with the prime minister
uh will obviously be in a covert secure
environment extra precautions will be
taken
but i think it is important that uh the
business and the
uh the the the the business of politics
if you like does
continue and doesn't stop uh doesn't
stop completely we just need to make
sure we take the right precautions
just finally the uk is hosting the cop
26 climate summit uh
in glasgow in november big deal know how
huge of course climate change is
globally but also for this
government as well some are saying it
should be done remotely how committed
are you to make sure it's done in person
well we think it should be done in
person physically
these are there is a cop secretariat or
a cop bureau that ultimately makes these
final decisions but they do so
in a really very close cooperation with
the host country
and we delayed it obviously last year
because we wanted it to happen in person
i think it's much more effective if it
does happen in person that's absolutely
our intention there may be
components of it that are
part virtual that some people attend
virtually but we think for the main
leader summit we should try and make
sure that it happens in person and
that's our intention
okay uh thank you very much for coming
on the programme uh this morning george
thank you
well we were just talking that about
climate change and next week the u.s
president joe biden is going to be
hosting another major summit of world
leaders to discuss the issue
his special envoy on climate the former
secretary of state john kerry this week
became the first biden administration
official to travel
to china now before he made that trip i
spoke to him
and began by asking how urgent it is
that the world takes action on climate
change
well it's extremely urgent i mean the
word urgent
is totally applicable to the current
crisis that we're in
because countries are simply not getting
the job done even if we did everything
that we set out to do in the paris
agreement
the earth's temperature is going to
increase a very significant amount
perhaps as much as 3.7 degrees or more
and the reason and the reason for the
real urgency now is that
because we're not getting done what we
said we do in paris it's actually
heading towards
four degrees or more that's beyond
catastrophic in the consequences to food
production
water habitability in various parts of
the planet the melting of ice the
sea level rise the warming all the
consequences
so we have an opportunity to get on
track the united states has a summit
next week
president biden is hosting and we will
be
setting forth our plan to try to do our
part and we hope
to raise ambition among all nations over
the course of these next months
as you say at the earth day summit uh
president biden is expected to
tell us what the us's emissions targets
are
given the fact that you're the second
biggest emitter in the world
and that you haven't even been in the
paris agreement in recent years
is it not the us's duty to actually set
the most ambitious targets in the world
well it's the us's duty certainly to
return to the paris agreement as
president biden has done
and to work with other nations to do the
maximum
possible i can assure you that the
united states will do its part
to help keep us on track
to have a 1.5 degree rise
the limit that's what that's our goal
and then to head to 2050 where we would
be net zero
and we hope that other nations will join
us
to raise the ambition to be able to hold
that 1.5 degree
limit on the increase of earth's
temperature obviously to do that we're
all going to have to do our part i mean
yes we are number two in the world in
emissions and
and we helped to put paris agreement
together and now we're going to do
everything in our power to help get
glasgow
to do what it needs to do to put the
world on a track in these next 10 years
to accomplish our goal
but the the simple reality is no one
nation does this alone even if the
united states went to zero tomorrow
where
the uk did or europe the fact is that
uh you know china which is almost 30 of
the world's emissions
other countries india russia indonesia
japan
there are a lot of industrialized
countries that are contributing to this
challenge
20 nations all of whom are invited to
president biden's summit
are responsible for about 81 percent of
all the emissions so
to solve this problem those 20 countries
have to lead the way
we recognize that responsibility we are
very sorry for uh the last four years
with the president who
didn't care about science and who didn't
have a real rationale for pulling out
but he was the only president in the
world the only leader in the world
who pulled out of this agreement
president biden said the first thing you
do as president is return
we've done that and now with this summit
we're going to try and bring nations to
the table to do what we need to do to
get the job done
for future generations of course there's
a responsibility as you say
on everyone but particularly those
countries that make up 80
of emissions at the same time you know
the us is responsible for
up to 15 percent of emissions china is
responsible for 30
you know some of our viewers might be
thinking is it really going to make a
difference if people in the uk
eat less meat or cycle more when you
consider these colossal emissions
coming out of the us and china
course it makes a difference because
every country has to join this effort
as i said a moment ago no one country no
one entity like the eu
can solve the problem this is this is a
unbelievable monument the climate crisis
to the need for multilateralism this is
why we have a un this is why we bring
nations together
and unfortunately the united states
became a renegade
in the last four years under the
non-leadership of president trump
but we are now back
and present with a very aggressive
series of initiatives in order to try to
make up for lost time
we need to address this challenge and
the beauty of it is
this creates jobs in in the addressing
of this in the deployment of solar of
wind
in the further explorations with respect
to hydrogen
fuel in the creation perhaps of storage
or longer term batteries
these are all jobs you make electric
vehicles you have people are going to
make them
i mean this is the biggest economic
opportunity the world has seen
since the industrial revolution nearly a
third of the
world's emissions come from china you
are planning to
travel to china this week to discuss
climate issues
we have been in touch with china i've
talked to my counterpart
a number of times we recognize that
china nearly 30 percent of the world's
emissions is essential
to resolving this crisis and our hopes
are that
china is prepared to assume
responsibility as we are
and as other nations are
this is not a moment where
any nation can not
step up to raise the ambition that paris
envisioned
uh and and what we're doing now is not
something that we've instigated
particularly
it's the automatic follow-on to the
paris agreement
that we would reconvene we will take
stock of where we are
there's a formal take stock in three
years but already
the u.n agency responsible for making
judgments about the science the ipcc
has told us two years ago that we have
about 12 years within which to make the
most critical decisions
to reduce the most damaging impacts of
climate
we're now two years down the road we
haven't done that yet
we have whatever nine years eight years
to make those decisions
and that's what glasgow is about it's a
moment when we all come together from
around the world
and we commit to do more there are of
course pretty big disagreements between
the us
and china on trade also you've described
the treatment of
the muslims as a genocide
can you really have a productive
conversation with client china about
climate change
absolutely of course we can climate
change is about the survival of the
planet
every nation has a stake in the outcome
of the climate issue
and and and big powerful nations
historically
have proven that they have the ability
to be able to discuss
difficult issues even as they disagree
on them
when i was secretary of state we dealt
very directly with russia even after
we had sanctioned them for the invasion
of crimea and ukraine
we continued to have tough conversations
about that even as we made progress on
the iran nuclear agreement on the paris
agreement
on other environment issues so yes uh
you know president reagan and mikhail
gorbachev met at reykjavik and lowered
the number of nuclear weapons pointing
at each other
despite the fact reagan thought the
soviet union was the evil empire
we can have those conversations and that
is the real stuff of diplomacy that's
what you have to do
is try you know the failure of diplomacy
is war
and the object of the diplomacy is to
avoid that i am keen to ask you about
the protests that we've seen
in minneapolis after another black man
shot by police cause it comes
after the killing of george floyd which
sparked protests around the world what's
your
reaction to what we've seen well
obviously
we're living through a very painful
moment in our country with respect to
race uh and uh policing
and the challenges of keeping
communities whole and together
we've had a terrible history
unfortunately
of police stops and
a relationship with african-americans
particularly but with
you know racial overtones for a long
period of time and we need to get
beyond it that's one of president
biden's
real missions that he has taken on is to
heal america and bring america back
together
uh but at the same time as i say that
and people are angry and frustrated at
the deaths
of people at the hands of uh you know
really
incomprehensible situations uh
nevertheless uh we
we also cannot condone or accept the
fact that the legitimate protest to that
is go out and loot a walmart or destroy
property protest is protest and it's
important that that protest
be non-violent otherwise you begin
confusing everything and losing
the importance of the message that you
have but these are serious uh
uh challenges and uh i used to be a
prosecutor i know how
difficult policing is but at the same
time
i also know the lives that
young african-americans particularly
have led in our country
being stopped in places and for
circumstances that no white person would
be stopped in
and so we have to meet that challenge
we've got some tough conversations to
have and some actions
to take one last quick question to
squeeze in because i know it's something
that we
talk about an awful lot in the uk uh
analyzing that relationship between the
uk prime minister and the us
president how would you describe the
relationship between joe biden and boris
johnson
well i the best of my knowledge they
they are friends and get along well and
and uh we're working together on a lot
of uh key
issues that matter to both of us so i
have no knowledge of anything else
it's my interview with john kerry there
and sky news has also launched the first
daily program dedicated to climate
issues
uh do check that one out it's presented
by my colleague anna jones you can catch
it every weekday at 6 30 and 9
30 in the evening
now let's return to the lobbying scandal
that's currently
front and center here in westminster
we're joined now by labour's shadow
community secretary
steve reed thanks very much for being in
the studio with us
today um we heard earlier in the program
from
george eustis who said that it's right
for all these questions to be looked at
he did say on the face of it that david
cameron didn't do anything wrong
and that the system in many ways is
actually
a pretty good one do you agree with him
well i think what we're seeing in all of
this is that the era of tory sleaze is
well and truly
as well and truly back and what's
happened with you know
the green seals scandal is really quite
shocking you've got a former prime
minister
employed by a wealthy organization who
is then using
his personal relationships with existing
ministers including the chancellor of
the exchequer
uh and persuading them to do favors
favors that would not have been open
to other businesses or they didn't
organization they didn't do the favors
did they
he didn't manage to persuade them to do
the favors they were rejected for their
we don't entirely know do
we because green still did get out
greenfield did get access to the
framework loan schemes
and it's not incli entirely clear how
they got access to that they were one of
only two unregulated banks
that were treated in that way we don't
know whether that was as a result of the
lobbying that david cameron was doing
now
what we've seen so far is a couple of
texts uh
exchanged between rishi sunak and david
cameron
in one of those the chancellor says that
he will push officials hard
to do favors for green sill that of
itself
may be a breach of the ministerial code
and that of itself
uh needs to be investigated because
ministers should be acting in a way that
is impartial and they should be pushing
things directly
onto their officials when this happens
but we haven't seen
all the texts or or the secret phone
calls that went on
between david cameron and rishi sunak
and we really need to
in order to understand exactly what's
going on going on we can't just dismiss
this
in the way that mr eustis tried to do
earlier this morning on your show
so what i'm interested in because i
think it's very easy for you know labor
to throw away
a throw around words like cronyism
notoriously as you did what exactly do
you want
to happen well what needs to change what
we've been calling for
is an open parliamentary investigation
into exactly what's been going on
there's
lots of investigations but we've got we
need an open
what do you want to actually happen this
is what this needs to change in the
world this hasn't just started with
green still so a year ago in the house
of commons
uh when we had robert generic the
community secretary
involved in the west ferry scandal he
was he admitted he had broken the law
to do favors for a billionaire tory
party donor and helped him dodge 40
billion pounds
just intact but the way to get around
this because
and i appreciate that there's lots of
concerns over lobbying about access
what needs to change well one of the
things that needs to change i'll use
that example if i can
if i can sophie because i wrote to the
cabinet secretary asking for an inquiry
into mr generic to see whether he had
broken the minister or code
the prime minister blocked it so the
inquiry didn't happen
and what what seems to be going on here
is that we've got you know the green
seal case
uh examples with matt hancock the
examples with west very
and robert generic in every case number
10 blocks the investigations
there's lots of investigations
well they're trying to mark their own
homework that you know the man that
they've put in charge of the green cell
investigation nigel boardman
is on the board of a bank with very
close links to the conservative there's
a lot of
other inquiries going on already it
feels to me like the problem isn't that
we haven't got enough inquiries we've
got loads of inquiries the problems is
no one seems to know
what should actually change to clean up
what we need is an open inquiry not one
where the conservatives are marking
their own homework
because boris johnson has shown
repeatedly over the past year he's not
interested in exposing what's going
wrong and he's not interested in
stopping
what's going wrong if we have an
independent parliamentary
inquiry into what's going on open and
transparent and david
cameron's own words sunlight is the best
disinfectant
well let's expose this whole situation
to that sunlight
let's see exactly what's going on let's
pull in everybody to
public hearings that the public can see
as well as mps let's find out what's
going on
and then let's put in place the measures
that will prevent it
from recurring one of them might well be
that the prime minister should not be
the person who decides
whether there are investigations into
his own ministers
for breaches of the ministerial code
perhaps an independent person should be
doing that
so the prime minister can't then be
accused of covering up wrongdoing by his
own ministers
is there an argument that labour would
be
just the same as this if you were in
power and if you look at the evidence
right if you look at this
for example david evans story in the
newspaper today
labour's general secretary won a series
of taxpayer contracts from croydon
council
labour on one council deputy leader
happens to be the mother of his child
is this evidence that if labour gets a
chance they would do exactly the same
thing it's just that the fact that
you're so far away from power
for so long
put this out and if that's the best they
can do to try and deflect from what
they're doing then it's a pretty
miserable attack okay how about this
what david was doing it was an open and
transparent procurement con
process which is the polar opposite of
what's been going on with green seal
or the con or the company that matt
hancock has shares in that he failed to
declare
that's been winning millions of pounds
in contracts
that's exactly the point he did he
didn't declare that his family had had
shares in this in this company
that's been winning millions of pounds
in congress
in exactly the way that he was obliged
to i don't think i i don't think he did
and that's why we need an investigation
into that as well
it's repeatedly happening with the
minister of ministry
defense secretary john healey also
lobbied the government to allow greens
access to covered lanes he says it was
the right thing to do because he was
trying to protect a steel plant in his
constituency
presumably david cameron thought it was
the right thing to do as well it's just
that he happened to have better
constituency mps
are asked to act on behalf of businesses
and their constituencies as constituency
mps
that's part of the job david cameron is
not an mp
david cameron was being employed by
green seal directly and being paid
to try and get them preferential
treatment from the chancellor of the
exchequer who was a friend of his whose
number he had on whatsapp an mp acting
for a local business
is a million miles away from what's been
going on with this situation
and i'm really i'm afraid you know the
kind of behavior we've been seeing from
this government is not the behavior you
would expect
of an advanced western democracy it's
what you would associate with a timpot
dictatorship
and britain deserves an awful lot better
than that we we have to shine a light
on the sleaze that is corroding the
heart of this government so we can stop
it
and get back to the kind of government
that the british people can have trust
in
okay i'm keen to ask you a couple more
things about clovid while i have you as
well now nhs providers are very worried
about the backlog
in the nhs caused by the pandemic they
said it could be five years to clear
how concerning is that well it's
incredibly concerning i've had
constituents coming to me now that have
had
very urgent operations for things like
cancer
delayed by months now frankly if you've
got cancer you can't afford to wait
for months i mean part of the problem
here is that the nhs had already been
underfunded by the time we went into
this
uh pandemic the pandemic was always
going to make it more more difficult
but we really need now to be looking at
everything that can be done to make sure
that people that have urgent treatment
needed in the nhs can
can go ahead and get it and one way to
do that is to make sure
that we keep a lid on on the situation
with covid right now so we have to keep
rolling out the vaccination
program but also we need to do much
better with
uh test contact tracing and testing
once we get out of this initial period
because new variants of the disease are
coming out
and we need to identify them and crack
down on them quickly third thing we need
to do is keep control of the borders
so the government still does not have a
comprehensive quarantine program should
david have people coming into the
country
should david cameron still be going to
tammy cameron her
slip should boris johnson still be going
to india given that
i think he shouldn't be no i mean there
are there are new variants emerging all
around
all around the world the government is
telling people don't travel if you don't
have to absolutely
travel i can't see why the prime
minister can't conduct his business
with the indian government by zoom so
many of us do that
these days and i think the prime
minister all of us in public life need
to try and set an example
of much rather the prime minister did it
by zoom than traveling to india
just finally you go poll this week gave
the conservatives a 14 point lead
over labour now i know it's just one
poll but you've got elections in just a
few weeks time and it feels like the
polls are going in the wrong
direction at what point you start to
panic it's just one poll let's wait and
see what happens in the elections
they're only they're only a few weeks
away after i've finished in your studio
i'm offering door knocking in
nottinghamshire with my colleagues so
i'm going to
hear what the voters have got to say and
we'll see on the 6th of may what they
what they think
okay thank you very much for coming on
the show today thank you well we just
mentioned the local elections there and
uh there are hundreds of races happening
across the uk at the moment
but politically some contests matter
more to boris johnson in kiersten than
others
well this week we've been looking at one
of those races the fight to be the next
mayor
of the west midlands
in the may 6th local election bonanza
this
is the place to watch if you want to
find out if labour has a fighting chance
against the conservatives in
england last time around labour's red
wall was breached
when tory candidate and former john
lewis boss andy street
won the race to be mayor of the west
midlands natalie and burn must prove
that labour can
win back those disaffected voters i
think most people in the labor movement
know that the the race in the west
midlands is probably the most important
race this year
that labour contends um you know the
defeat that we had in in december 2019
was really significant and a lot of
people actually in the media and
elsewhere have underestimated
um quite the you know the the depth of
that defeat there's been some criticism
about kyocera's leadership about people
not knowing
what he stands for do you think that's
fair
when we take care out and about in the
west midlands through
we're trying walking through markets and
that kind of thing um
there's a real enthusiasm to actually
you know come over have a chat
um listen talk share some views he's
clever
he's he's intelligent and he's
straightforward anybody who's kind of
watching
prime minister's questions and just
watching the forensic way he
he takes a takes apart boris the
blusterer
um you know people just sort of respect
that at the same time though um you're
obviously critical of boris johnson but
he did manage to take six seats off
labor at the last election in 2019 in
your area
it feels like people in the west
midlands might quite like the idea of
boris johnson as well
i spent more time on the streets of the
west midlands during
that election than pretty much any other
politician in our region
and i can tell you overwhelmingly what
people talked about
was brexit and jeremy corbyn
and even amongst many tories i met
people who said you know they'd always
been voting tory
you tended to find people say well we do
kind of think that it's time for a
change
i'm afraid we don't like mr corbyn
and people would often describe boris as
a bit of a clown
and they and so they they weren't in
love with that they did want to get
brexit done and you know the
truth was they didn't trust their leader
at the time you should beat andy street
easily then is that what you're
anticipating
yeah it is yeah i mean you know
obviously it's difficult when
you don't have polls um we found door
locking has gone really well people are
quite keen
uh people are quite pleased to see us
kind of turn up um
and our numbers coming back look great
so yeah i think we're gonna i think
we're gonna
we'll do well what do you think the main
issues are
of you that you're fighting on in the
west midlands the number one issue by a
mile
is jobs jobs jobs people are super
worried about
um the economy uh the livelihoods of
small business
and basically how we get on it back on
our feet as fast as possible
the conservative party candidate is duly
elected
as mayor for the west midlands combined
authority
andy street who narrowly won the 2017
election to become
the region's first mayor agrees that
recovery from coronavares needs to be
the priority
so i think there's one overwhelming
issue sophie and that's
how we're going to bounce back from the
pandemic so obviously this was a region
that was performing very well before the
pandemic but we've had a
horrible swipe swipe left from the
pandemic lots of job losses so the big
question is
who is going to lead the economic
recovery of this region
this contest is also going to be looked
through the prism of boris johnson
versus kirstama as well um you know it's
a region that is a key
electoral battleground for both parties
both labor and conservatives really need
to win it frankly
the conservatives obviously did better
in 2019
how do you think kiss dama goes down in
the red wall then
i'm waiting to see the answer to that
this election will tell us something
about that
what i hope it will tell us is actually
the
idea that we did very well in the red
wall on the back of
brexit and the feeling about jeremy
corbyn and that was about it i
think we will prove that's wrong i think
what's going to be proved
is that support for the conservative
party
in the areas that we describe as the
report is actually about something much
much deeper and primarily it's about
local conservatives
whether they be mps mayors or local
councils
really delivering for people if you
think of the investment
that's come into the black country come
into northfield the only
seat that we want in birmingham come
into these areas there is clear
evidence that conservatives deliver for
the areas that arguably been left behind
that's what it's really all about i just
speak to liam byrne before talking to
you
i have to say he seemed pretty confident
he seemed to think that he was going to
win
quite comfortably are you worried i
don't think anyone's going to win
comfortably i think it's going to be
very very close
uh race the last mayoral race was very
close the general election was very
close here
so i'm prepared to predict it'll be
close again
and uh i'm actually quite surprised that
he was confident because
i think the feedback i get is that it's
really really contested
we are confident of our position but no
it's going to be very very
close in the end to give a sense of how
close
this race could be there are 28
westminster constituencies across the
region that the west midlands
mayor controls in the last general
election in 2019
14 of them were won by the conservative
party
the other 14 were won by labour nearly
1.2 million votes were cast but there
was less than 3 000 votes
between the two main parties and the
west midlands was part of a wider story
six previously labor seats some of which
have been held by the party for decades
turned blue as boris johnson ate into
the so-called red wall
and it's this that gives the west
midlands race an added significance
it will be an indicator of how far boris
johnson has kept those red wool voters
on side
and a test of kirsten's ability to win
them back to labour
it will be a setback for the government
if they don't hold this everything
suggests it's going to be tight
it was tight last time around when andy
street uh managed this surprise
victory you've got really uh factors on
either side that are quite hard to
calculate
on his side he's very popular for his
business background for the
john lewis history that he has for the
real efforts that he's made to improve
uh the area but he's been quite quiet
he's a reserved personality
and he's had what you might say as a
handicap um
during the pandemic of coming from the
same party as the government
that's not a problem that has affected
labour mayors i think it is the kind of
place where kiestama has to
show that he's he's getting through to
people that he's got something to say
the race for the west midlands is
unusually seen as a must win for both
parties
whatever happens on the 6th of may it's
likely to be very close
my piece from the west midlands there um
and let's now take a quick look at the
full list of candidates who are standing
to be the region's mayor
lynn byrne is standing for labour steve
caldwell
for the green party pete darnell for
reform uk
andy street for the conservatives and
jenny wilkinson
for the liberal democrats those
candidates there to be the
mayor of the west midlands
well that's one of the key races in
england but of course a huge election is
also taking place in scotland the snp
fighting to win a majority not only to
keep them in power but to secure a
mandate
for a second independence referendum
their leader
nicholas sturgeon joins us now from
glasgow thank you very much for being uh
with us
sturgeon um before we talk about the
election i just want to ask you very
quickly about
covid in scotland the decision was taken
to speed up the easing
of lockdown there are these concerns
about a new variant first identified
in india how concerned are you and are
you prepared to slow things down again
if necessary
well if necessary of course we have to
do that but i fervently hope it won't be
necessary we're making good progress
here case numbers are
falling the vaccination rollout is going
exceptionally well but the big risk we
face
not just in scotland but across the uk
right now is the
importation of new variants of the virus
variants that might be faster spreading
that might be
more severe and crucially variants that
might undermine
the efficacy of the vaccine so we've got
to be very
very careful about that which is why i
think one of the restrictions we're all
going to have to live with
for longer is a restriction on
international travel
in scotland we insist that people
quarantine
in managed isolation at wherever in the
world they come to if they come directly
into scotland and we continue to try to
persuade the uk government to take a
similar approach because
we mustn't allow the progress we're
making domestically to be undermined
by two lacks of position on
international travel it's very difficult
for the sector
and it's really important that
governments support it as we try to
continue to protect ourselves
against the virus we spoke to george
eustis a bit earlier on the program he
said that
at the moment there doesn't seem to be
evidence that the
variant first found in india is more
contagious
all that it evades the vaccine is that
your understanding as well
so far that would be my understanding
it is at the moment uh a variance of
interest as opposed to
a variant of concern but i think the
thing we've got to recognize about covid
is that it is mutating and we're seeing
new variants appear in different parts
of the world the
variant of course that has caused us in
scotland and other parts of the uk
the most uh problem over the last few
months is the the kent variant the one
that uh
led us all into lockdown again uh over
christmas and into the early part of
this year
so we don't know where the variants of
real concern are going to come from
which is why an approach to
international travel that tries to
categorize risk with some countries
categorized as redless countries and
other countries deemed to be safer
i think poses a risk because none of us
know right now
where the next variant that might be
really problematic is going to
occur which is why unfortunately and i
take no pleasure in saying this because
it's really
difficult for the aviation sector
reports tourism
we've got to be very careful as we
continue to suppress things at home
we've got to be careful we don't allow
it to be reseeded
with more dangerous variants from
elsewhere i mean if i look back to
last summer the later part of last
summer as we came out of the first
lockdown
we almost eliminated the strains that
were circulating within scotland here
but we probably opened up international
travel too quickly so we
allowed the virus to reseed into our
domestic population and i think it's
important we try as hard as we can
to avoid that in the weeks and months
ahead yeah the importance of
learning the lessons from the previous
year um i'm
keen to talk now a bit about your
domestic record
uh ahead of the all-important elections
coming up
uh in may and specifically just to start
on education
so in 2015 before the last election you
said
my priority as first minister and let me
be clear i want to be judged on this
is that every young person should have
the same advantage that i had
growing up now research from glasgow
university last year found
what it describes as staggering
inequality
in scotland schools pupils who live in
the most deprived fifth of communities
are just as likely to leave school with
just one hire
our students in the most prosperous
fifth leave with five
so does every scotland every child in
scotland have the same advantages as you
had growing up
not yet i think we've still got work to
do but more of those young people have
greater advantages now than was the case
five years ago and let me be clear i
will be judged on this as i will be
judged on
everything in just a couple of weeks
time at the election if you take the
attainment gap in particular and i know
the qualification system is different in
scotland
to other parts of the uk so apologies if
i'm about to use terminology that not
everybody will understand but
at what we call level five which is our
national fives the attainment gap has
reduced by a third
at level six which is our highest it has
reduced by a fifth there's work
to do we've expanded dramatically early
years education which everybody accepts
is the biggest investment you can make
in reducing the attainment gap later in
a young person's school education
and we also have now and you know this
is something that's important to me as
somebody who was the first person in my
family to go to university
we now have record numbers of people
from
poorer more deprived communities going
into higher education
so we've made significant progress but
we still got work to do we would
undoubtedly have made
more progress had we not faced
the disruption as everybody has faced
over the past year with covid so
there remains a lot of work to do and
one of the reasons i'm asking people to
re-elect me as first minister the snp is
government
is so that we can get on with that job
we're probably the only party in this
election
that is putting a serious plan for
government before the scottish people
you can't blame this all uh on the
pandemic they
did if you look at the uh but
if you look at the statistics from
before the pandemic for example the pass
rate behind exams gone down over the
last four years 79
in 2015 75 now i mean that's happening
on your watch isn't it
sorry just to be clear sophia i think
people listening to me would not have
heard me try to blame everything
uncovered
equally i think most people understand
that covet has
an impact on every aspect of our life
but if you look across the last five
years
at all of the statistics what you see in
scotland
is increasing attainment so people at
young people coming out of school with
more
qualifications and the attainment gap
reducing
and more young people particularly from
deprived communities going into
university and indeed going on to
positive destinations overall i am not
going to sit here
um and say that it is job done and i
think there is
more to do not am i going to apologize
for uh setting
big ambitions and saying to people judge
me on
the record of my government overall
people will make a balanced judgment on
whether they think the snp has a good
record in government and
the evidence suggests that people don't
think we're perfect but people think
we're the party to be trusted
with taking scotland forward and they'll
look at the other parties as well
one of the interesting features of the
scottish election is that the other
parties are all vying
to be leader of the opposition in these
really serious times
scotland deserves a party that is
serious about government
serious about facing up to the
challenges of government leading us
through the crisis and into recovery and
that's what i and the snp offer
okay is the smp a party that is serious
about funding the nhs because
this week you promised a
transformational increase in nhs funding
the ifs says that actually the rise is
less than the rise planned for england
and it's actually unlikely to keep up
with demand so is the rhetoric better
than the reality here
can i come on to that in a moment
because i want to take that on directly
and
i think it's wrong but you know this is
one
area where i don't need to ask people to
judge me on what i'm promising for the
future
it judge me on the past so at the last
scottish election
i made a commitment that we would
increase funding in the national health
service by at 500 million pounds
in real terms in reality we've done
three times
that at the nhs budget over the past
five years has increased by
uh 1.8 billion pounds in real terms so
you know you don't have to change the
bank what you're promising
now and you promised a transformational
increase in nhs funding
this works out as it is 2.1
above inflation in england it's 3.4
percent and i
can i come on to that point but i think
i actually think it is it is legitimate
to say to people look
you you have pitched these questions out
look at my record so
i'm pointing to the record where we
actually exceeded the commitment we made
but on that point the ifs have looked at
the position
so there's two points to make here the
ifs have looked at the position in
england up to 2023 that's the only
uh the time frame in which the uk
government have made a commitment in
england
the commitment i've made for the next
parliament takes us up to 2026 so it's
apples and pears to make the comparison
that you have made but the other point
and this is a key point
is that in a sense the commitment i have
made is a backstop
whatever the budgetary position that the
uk government
delivers for scotland we will deliver
that transformational 20
increase in health funding but if the uk
government exceeds that and that is
extra money comes through the barnet
formula
we will commit that to the nhs as well
so by definition
we cannot be spending less than the uk
government does
in england because the commitment we've
made is the back stop
and if the barnet formula allows us to
go further we will go further but you
know we
exceeded our commitment at the last
election and we will deliver this
commitment
at least over the next parliament a 20
increase in nhs funding which amounts to
2.5
billion pounds extra money for social
care over and above that which the ifs
analysis also doesn't take into account
and
also shifting the balance of investment
so much more is going into community
health care
and mental health care too okay um
another area
i'm keen to talk about as well is drugs
scotland suffers more drug deaths per
capita than any other
european country over 1200 people dying
of drug you've misused last year
that's a record high for the sixth year
in a row how is that acceptable it's not
um and i've been very candid about that
we
have tried to tackle the drugs deaths
but we can't look at the figures for the
numbers of people
dying and conclude that what we have
done has been
enough or has been effective enough so
over the past few months we've done a
number of things
to make a concerted attempt to turn this
around so firstly
i have appointed a dedicated minister
with
responsibility for this reporting
directly
to me we have set aside a budget over
the next few years
of 250 million pounds to specifically
support initiatives
to tackle the drugs crisis and drugs
deaths and that is supporting more
community work it is supporting a
greater
provision of rehabilitation beds
including residential rehabilitation and
after-care support faster access to
treatment so that if somebody comes
forward looking for treatment they get
that quickly and aren't
having to wait for that so there is a
whole package
of policies and interventions now that
we are taking forward to turn it around
because to be frank it's not
acceptable and you know you can make
choices as a politician you can be
confronted with something like that and
try to dig your heels in and defend
the indefensible or you can do what i
think is better and
admit that this is an area where we have
not done well enough and we're
determined to do better in future
you see it sounds very good what you're
promising it sounds very candid it
sounds like
you know you're very keen to point out
what you want to change in the future
but people will be wondering where has
this been over the last 14 years that
the snp has been in power
when there's been a 160 rise in drug
deaths
and a 55 cut in real terms funding for
alcohol and drug services
is it too late look we didn't get it
right it's not because we didn't care
it's not because we weren't trying
to do things but you know we have
concluded
because i don't think we can do anything
else that we haven't got it right now i
could sit here and i could
try to set out some of the reasons why
scotland may have a higher
number of drugs deaths in other
countries reasons that go back
many decades in some respects are having
your higher drug use in the days when i
was growing up an older
drug using population with multiple
morbidities
i could see all of that and some of that
would you know be legitimate and and be
part of the explanation but i'm choosing
instead to say
we haven't done well enough here we
haven't yet
uh implemented the the policies that
have turned us around so we're going to
redouble our efforts we're going to try
different things now
i could also sit here and say that
aspects of the
the levers over this are reserved so the
classification of
drugs whether or not we can have safe
consumption rooms which is something
most experts in scotland want to see the
the levers of control of these things
still lie with westminster we don't have
all of the levers in our own hands now i
could say all of that
and all of that would have some
legitimacy but i'm actually choosing
instead to take
responsibility for not having done well
enough and for setting out
in great detail what we're going to do
to put it right i hope in future
i've been keen you know in the interview
to look back at your records
in government because it really matters
because you're effectively asking the
scottish people to trust you
to lead an independent scotland so it
really
matters you're clearly an exceptional
communicator you're clearly somebody who
has strong approval ratings relative to
other politicians
but if you look at the facts record drug
deaths after 14 years of an s p
government
still inequalities they're in education
although you admit
that in some areas there's been
improvement there are still big
inequalities when it comes to education
the highest rate of care home resident
deaths from covered
in the uk why should people trust you to
lead an independent scotland
sorry sophie the number of care home
deaths in scotland is
far too high and it shouldn't be a
statistical competition
but i i really do have to challenge that
the the number of excess deaths in
k homes in england has been much higher
than in
in scotland or higher than in scotland
in scotland we have
recorded more of them as as covert
deaths so
i will challenge that but that is not
saying that it is not the case that the
number of covet
deaths and care homes the number of
covered deaths overall hasn't been too
high because it has been
like people will decide whether they
trust me or not that's what elections
are all about i'll put my record in
front of the people of scotland i'll
point to all of the things
we have done over the past term of
parliament we have
established a new social security system
in scotland we've established
a scottish child payment which is
lifting children out of poverty
at the level of child poverty too high
but lower in scotland than in any other
part of
the uk we have made progress in closing
the attainment gap we've led the country
through the covered pandemic i'll also
be candid
with people because i think it's better
to do that than the opposite
about where i think we haven't got
things right or where we have
more work to do and then people will
make a judgment about who they
trust most to lead the country through
covet
to get us into recovery and we put
before the scottish people a bold
ambitious
transformative program for recovery from
covet
and then after covered when the time is
right to decide
the future of scotland whether we should
leave big decisions in the hands of
politicians like boris johnson or
whether we should take those decisions
into our own hands as an independent
country so that we can
shape the long-term future of scotland
in the way we want it to be and people
will make their judgments about that
they'll look at me my record what i
offer people
and they'll look at the opposition and
the competition as well and they'll
cast their verdict on may the 6th that's
democracy and i embrace it thoroughly
um alex salmond has launched a new party
to help build a super majority for
scottish independence you must be very
grateful for his help
look he can speak for himself we need a
simple majority
in the scottish parliament to give us
the mandate for an independence
referendum and then of course we need a
majority of the scottish people to win
independence and you know when i listen
to people who talk about super
majorities they sound as if they think
we can just build those our way to
independence which is almost
contemptuous
uh towards those that we need to
persuade
the many many people i
i listen to the the rhetoric around
independence and it seems to skip
over the need to do the hard work of
persuading those who voted no in 2014
uh many of whom are now open-minded i
know many of these people but want to be
persuaded and want to be treated with
respect and want
us to make a convincing persuasive case
to them and
that's the hard work that i've been
doing polling for independence is at a
higher level now than it's ever been
but we've got to continue with that hard
work with that respectful discourse and
that's how we win independence and
you know i'm not particularly interested
in an arm wrestling contest with other
people about who supports independence
the most
that's a conversation with ourselves i'm
interested in persuading those who are
open-minded but need still to be
persuaded so that we build a majority
for independence that then expresses
itself in a legitimate process
because that's how we win independence
and that's what i want to do
in the spirit of respectful discourse if
alba does win seats at the election
would you
work with alex salmond no i'm not going
to work with alex salmond
firstly i have concerns about his
personal conduct that he hasn't
acknowledged or
apologized for as i've just said i i
don't
agree with the approach to independence
because i think it is
more or is risking putting people off
rather than bringing people towards us
there's no shortcut to independence
we've got to do it through
winning a majority and allowing that
majority to express itself in a
legitimate process i also
don't know what alba stands for for me
independence is not an end in itself
it's
a means to a better scotland a fair uh
equal scotland where we value everybody
who lives here
for who they are and i don't know what
albus stands for but
from what i've seen so far i i probably
would have some concerns about that
okay um just finally we talked a lot
about lobbying
on the program this morning the snp
minister fergus ewing had a dinner
with lex grunsel and sanjeev gupta in
2017. this is according to the sunday
mail
no officials were there no notes were
taken
if there's no record of what happened
how do we know it's above board
well it was recorded in the usual way in
the the register
of meetings look i understand the
temptation
to draw an analogy between the the
scandal that we see developing around
david cameron
around the uk government and the
scottish government is dealing with gfg
the two things are very different we
work directly with gfg
to firstly uh save the dl steel works in
2015 there was virtually nobody employed
there today
employs more than a hundred people and
secondly with that company to save the
local
aluminium smelter and you know there's
more than 100 jobs have been protected
there with more created as a result the
guarantee that was agreed
to support that takeover of the smelter
the
committee of the scottish parliament
approved that so there it's not the the
lobbying
scandal that we see elsewhere and i
think people should be careful in trying
to draw
that analogy with all the proper due
diligence has been done
things like the the way in which green
cell has tried to to use the nhs
which david cameron allegedly lobbied
for that's not happened
in scotland and we've not had you know
some of the stuff around
covered loans so i can see the
temptation but the two things are not
the same
okay nicolas sturgeon thank you very
much for being on the program today
thank you
quick reminder before we go do check out
the sofie ridge on sunday podcast we're
talking about that interview with
nicolas sturgeon
it will be available from lunchtime on
the sky news app or wherever you
usually listen to your podcast after
this break it's sophie bridge the take
where we can go over everything we just
heard from my interviews
don't go anywhere
[Music]
you